et puis vous êtes la marraine de la
nouvelle promo de la Star Ac alors
évidemment cette émission nouvelle
formule qu'est-ce qu'on dit Oh qu'est-ce
qu'on dit aux jeunes là quand on les
regarde évoluer ben ça me fait un peu
peur moi à chaque fois je vois des des
très très jeune enfin mais en même temps
ben ce que je leur dis c'est de s'amuser
de savourer le moment présent profiter
des cours et de la compétition envers
soi-même parce que souvent dans
on attise un peu les choses dans le
mauvais sens du terme c'est-à-dire que
moi je redoute toujours les là où on
doit voter moi j'ai ce traumatisme de
quand je dois voter entre deux copains
quoi alors l'œil gauche ou l’œil droit
qu'est-ce que tu préfères c'était un peu
le choix de Sophie là et j'ai ce
souvenir là donc juste qu'il prenne soin
de deux déjà de se protéger et surtout
que nous on n'avait pas toutes ces
machines auparavant on n'avait pas
l'accès à des réseaux sociaux on n'avait
pas les téléphones portables et tout
n'était pas développé comme comme
aujourd'hui
avait été à l'époque dans l'air des
réseaux sociaux de cette surexposition
je sais pas et je crois pas je crois pas
même sur une saison 2 parce que j'aurais
vu comment ça se passe et j'aurais eu
peur
de me perdre à un moment donné moi je
redoute à chaque fois de me transformer
en robot de perdre ma vraie nature c'est
comme à force de regarder des enfin de
tomber dans une caricature ou de d'avoir
une certaine posture qui n'était pas la
mienne et puis mais je crois que bon ça
se serait vu déjà direct parce que
sincèrement j'ai du mal à mentir mais
mais je crois que ça m'aurait trop
effrayé d'être filmé comme ça dans
l'intime bon après ils sont vachement
axés sur les cours c'est vrai que c'est
pas le loft non plus c'est pas d'autres
émissions de terrain était que je
respecte chacun chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il entend mais moi c'est pas
quelque chose dans un exercice dans
lequel je me serais senti à l'aise
qu'on voit au réveil et tout ça je passe
ça m'aurait un peu vous êtes tombé dans
la marmite vous sentez que ça y est vous
êtes piqué aux vif par par je sens qu'il
y a en gros c'est il y a que ça qu'il y
a que ça qui me plaît il y a que ça qui
ne m'ennuie pas il y a que ça qui me
je sais pas qui me fait du bien qui me
guide et qui qui m'aide à
vous canaliser peut-être parce que
l'école
quelques bêtises maman et data veille
il y a toujours eu la famille autour
heureusement ouais c'est vrai que j'ai
de bonnes bases maintenant vous auriez
pu déraper oui bien sûr j'aurais pu
déraper ouais mais largement
c'est-à-dire plein de fois
c'est à dire que
que je voulais faire les choses toute
seule très vite trop tôt et puis et puis
et puis il y a eu des mauvaises
rencontres aussi parfois ça j'aurais pu
me laisser influencer j'ai été
fragile il fallait pas que je déçoivent
autour de moi la Star Ac en effet arrive
avec avec un concept avec toute une une
espèce de grosse machinerie énorme
vous vous sentez comment au début
là-dedans pas bien du tout mais au début
c'était je passe la dernière au casting
je me posais la question est-ce que je
participe parce que j'y participais je
suis la dernière à passer j'étais cachée
sous une table on vient me chercher
c'est à vous et je vois en fait même il
y avait Pascal à l'époque à
l'extérieur Joubert qui sorte en fait
comme si les auditions étaient terminées
et puis donc du coup je dis bon ok il
sorte bon bah vas-y j'y suis j'y vais et
je donne tout vous savez danser oui bien
sûr et je lève la jambe enfin je chante
enfin je sais pas je et on me rappelle
j'étais dans le métro ouais ok vous avez
été retenu ok donc vous serez chez plus
combien sur le prime foulard blanc pour
la bleue et là et puis après il gardait
les 16 candidats qui allaient rentrer
dans le château et là mais là je me
fissure c'est à dire que j'étais je
savais que j'allais pas y rentrer c'est
pas possible j'avais une nonchalance qui
était pas on adéquation avec la soif et
l'envie de certains talents quoi et puis
j'y vais et puis je sors du jeu je suis
gagnant donc c'est quand même
complètement fou mais encore j'ai encore
un regard mais tellement je suis
tellement admirative comme beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de gens
et j'ai ce privilège de pouvoir aller
partager mais en plus j'étais devant 60
000 personnes
j'avais les cordes vocales complètement
rétractées
et j'avais 20 ans j'étais enceinte de
mon premier enfant donc avec les
hormones qui font les bons j'avais tout
vu la totale de vomi avant de monter
juste avant de monter magnifique j'avais
peur qu'ils sentent que j'avais de
mauvaise haleine
j'avais peur de pas être à la hauteur
vous lui avez dit que vous étiez
ensemble oui mais j'ai beaucoup ri avec
lui j'ai beaucoup ri avec lui sur tout
sur les répétitions et tout on a été
amené à chanter quelques fois ensemble
et
j'ai eu toujours eu énormément de
tendresse venant de sa part et
je sais pas comme un truc comme si
ils comprenait on n'avait pas besoin de
s'expliquer même parfois et
je sais pas c'est vraiment une rencontre
qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup beaucoup
apporté sur le plan artistique sur le
plan
personnel aussi et il m'a donné les
meilleurs conseils que que j'ai pu
recevoir c'est évidemment vertigineux un
tel moment au Parc des Princes est
tellement avec Johnny Hallyday et puis
parce qu'il est aussi l'idole de votre
papa et puis
c'était l'idole de toute la famille
entière quoi mais l'idole de tout le
monde c'est pas possible on peut pas ils
ont pu se rencontrer je crois ouais j'ai
fait en sorte qu'il se rencontre ouais
mon père c'est la première fois que je
vois mon père avec vraiment les larmes
aux yeux là pour le coup c'est ça a été
beaucoup d'émotions pour lui aussi
donc fierté absolue forcément ma fille
va chanter avec Johnny quoi c'était la
classe